ركزوا معي علشان هحكي لكم قصه غريبه شويه
اللي قدامنا دي هي مدينه تايلاند في جنوب
تايوان في سنه 1963 اتولد فيها طفل كبرت
طفل ولما بقى عنده تسع سنين هجره اسرته
لولايه كنتاكي الامريكيه وبعدها استقرف
ولايه اوريجون الطفل اللي بحكي لكم عليه
ده اسمه جونسون سنه 1984 وانج اخذ شهادته
جمعيه في الهندسه الكهربائيه من جامعه
ولايه اورجون واشتغل في تصميمه
في شركه ادفانسي معروفه اختصارا بعدها
بثمن سنين وفي سنه 1992 اخد درجه
الماجستير في نفس التخصص من جامعه
ستانفورد وبعدها بسنه على طول في 1993 اسس
هو واثنين صحابه شركه صغيره لتصنيع رقائق
الكمبيوتر اللي بتعالج الرسومات وتحديدا
العاب الفيديو شركه اسمها فيديو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
النهارده في وقت تصوير الحلقه وبعد 30 سنه
من تاسيسه لشركته ومرورها بتقلبات ضخمه
وصولها لحافه الافلاس اكتر من مره بعد ده
كله نقدر نعتبر ان هو واحد من اهم واكتر
الاشخاص نفوزا في العالم حكومات دول
وشركات عالميه عملاقه يتمنوا له الرضا
يرضى وبيشتروا لدرجه انهم بيعتبروه بطل
قومي في وطن الام تايوان بلا مبالغه الشعب
التايواني بيقابله بالورود والاحضان
والناس نفسها تاخد صوره معه من اقل من
اسبوعين في يوم 27 مايو اللي فات ده القى
خطاب للخريجين في جامعه تايوان الوطنيه
وبعد ما تم تقديمه للطلبه بوصف فخر تايوان
الف الخطاب بتاعه جمله واحده مهمه جدا نصح
بها الطلبه نصيحه بخصوص حياتهم العمليه
ولخص فيها فلسفته في الشغل على
[موسيقى]
يقصد ان الشخص في شغله لازم يكون سابق
اللي حواليه بخطوات علشان ما يتحولش لصيد
سهله للي حواليه النهج ده هو اللي وصل
للحظه الحاليه ايه هي اللحظه الحاليه دي
بقى اللحظه دي هي ان شركه انفيديا اللي
كانت هتفلس اكتر من مره من ساعه انشاءها
زي ما قلنا تضاعفت قيمتها ثلاث مرات في
اقل من تمن شهور بشكل مفاجئ علشان قيمتها
السوقيه تتخطى التريليون دولار وتبقى اكبر
شركه اشباه موصلات في العالم حاليا واحده
من اكبر الشركات قيمه في التاريخ ايه بقى
قصه شركه انفيديا الامريكيه المثيره دي
وليه قيمتها تضاعفت في الكام شهر اللي
فاتوا ووصلت لتريليون دولار وازاي الشركه
بقت فجاه بتمتلك نفوس ضخم على دول وشركات
كبرى في العالم وايه علاقه شركه تي اس ام
سي التايوانيه بالقصه دي وازاي انفيديا في
هدوء ومن غير ما حد ياخد باله ادت
المنافسين بتوعها بالقلم على قفاهم دي
عينه من الاسئله المهمه جدا اللي هندردش
حوا ليها في حلقه النهارده بس قبل ما نبدا
بفكركم بالاشتراك في القناه لان اشتراكم
ده هو اللي بيخلي محتوانا ينتشر ويظهر
للناس بفكركم برضو ان حلقاتنا اللي فاتت
كلها مترجمه للغه الانجليزيه فما تنسوش
تشاركوها مع اصحابكم الاجانب وتعرفوهم
علينا انا اشرف ابراهيم ده المقبل
الاقتصادي
عايز اشكر شركه العالميه لرعايتها الحلقه
دي وهي شركه عندها خبره طويله في الاسواق
الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز الاتنين
تريليون دولار ليه بنصح بالتعامل مع علشان
اربع مميزات الاولى انها مرخصه ومراقبه من
هيئات رقبيه التانيه بعرف اسحب فلوسي فيها
بشكل فوري بدون تدخل بشري التالته ان
عملتهم منخفضه الرابعه ان التداول بيتنفس
بسرعه تقدر تفتح حساب اسلامي لا محدود
وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم والدهب هتلاقوا
لينك لهم تحت الفيديو وفي تعليقات فيسبوك
في اوائل التسعينات هو واثنين مهندسين
اصدقائه هم كريسما لاتشوسكي وكارت كانوا
متعودين يقعدوا في فرع من فروع سلسله
مطاعم مشهوره وزيهم زي كتير من الشباب في
اواخر العشرينات فكروا يعملوا مشروع بدل
الوظيفه كانوا عاوزين يعملوا حاجه مختلفه
وكانوا بيتوقعوا مع تطور الحواسيب ففي
حاجه هتكون ملاحه ومطلوبه في ادائها وهو
تحسين معالجه المرئيات المع كان عندهم
احلام ازاي يمكنوا اجهزه الكمبيوتر من
الرسومات ثلاثيه الابعاد الثقيله زي العاب
الفيديو لو حضراتكم تفتكروا اول جهاز
كمبيوتر اشتريتوه او اشتغلتوا عليه كان
يقول لك مثلا جهازك مش هيستحمل اللعبه دي
علشان تقيله لازم تشتري له كارت الكارت ده
بقى عباره عن شرائح او رقائق بتحاول رموز
الكمبيوتر لصور واقعيه يقدر هو الالعاب
يشوفوها قدامهم على الشاشه البدايه كانت
من هنا للتلات شباب دول اللي انشاوا
المشروع الواعد ده وبالفعل اطلقوا شركتهم
من شقه في ولايه كاليفورنيا سنه 1993 براس
مال 40,000 دولار وسموها انفيديا والاسم
مستوحى من حرفين اللي هم الان والفي هم
اختصار لكلمه نكس فيرجن او الاصدار التالي
فاختاروا كلمه وهي كلمه لاتينيه للحسد
لانهم كانوا بيعملوا في تسريح الحوسبه
للحد اللي يخلي الكل يحسدهم بس يكون حسد
غير مذموم يعني فاختاروا العين الخضراء
الحسوده كشعار للشركه في الوقت ده كان في
حوالي عشرين شركه بيصنعوا وحده معالجه
الرسومات ولكن انفيديا اثبتت انها الاكثر
نجاحا وسط اقرانها في تطوير وحدات معالجه
الرسومات وقدروا يصمدوا قدام موجه
الافلاسات او الاندماجات اللي المنافسين
بتوعها وقعوا فيها او عملوها علشان يبقوا
اما شركات اكبر حجما او تحت شركات اكبر
وفي الالفينات فازت انفيديا بعقد لصنع
رقائق لوحه التحكم العاب
من وقتها استمرت انفيديا في النمو مع
انفجار سوق العاب الفيديو لدرجه انه تجاوز
الصناعات الافلام والتلفزيون والموسيقى في
الحجم والقيمه وتحت قياده وانك بتنمو
بتتوسع وبتنطح منافسها كبار وعلى راسهم
طبعا المنافسه في السوق ده كانت دمويه
وانفيديا كانت لها محاولات فاشله كتير في
العديد من مشاريع التوسعيه على مدار
السنين زي بناء رقائق للاجهزه المحموله
مثلا لكن استراتيجيه في التغلب على
المنافسين كانت بب التركيز على الابتكار
والتحرك السريع وفتح اسواق جديده لوحدات
معالجه الرسومات وكان شايف الخطر الاكبر
في الاستمرار في تقديم خدماتهم لجمهور
متخصص في العاب الفيديو عن طريق صنع نوع
رقائق كمبيوتر اللي بيخدم احتياجاتهم بس
من هنا قرر يراهن بكل شيء ويوجه
الاستثمارات وجهود في الشركه الابتكار
وظائف اضافيه لرقائق انفيديا يعني ما
تبقاش مقتصر على الالعاب بس في 2006
باحثين في جامعه ستانفورد اكتشفوا استخدام
تاني لوحدات معالجه الرسومات هيخليها تقدر
تسرع العمليات الحسابيه بطريقه ما تقدرش
تعملها رقائق المعالجه العاديه استثمر كل
موارد انفيديا في انشاء اداه لجعل وحدات
معالجه الرسومات قابله للبرمجه وفي نفس
السنه انشات انفيديا منصه كودا اللي من
خلالها قدرت تعيد توظيف وحدات معالجه
الرسومات كمسرعات لانواع تانيه من
الاستخدامات غير الرسومات في سنه 2009
طورت انفيديا وحدات معالجه الرسومات
عرض الصور لاجهزه كمبيوتر من خلال تفوقها
في معالجه مهام صغيره كتيره في وقت واحد
زي مثلا معالجه ملايين وحدات البيكسل على
الشاشه الاجراء ده عرف باسم المعالجه
المتوازنه وبالتالي ده فتح امكانات تانيه
لاستخدامات تتجاوز الرسومات وركزوا يا
اخواننا في التحول اللي بيحصل ده التطورات
دي خلت الفيديو تتحول لتصنيع شرائح لخوادم
او سيرفرات مراكز البيانات ودي منطقه كانت
بتسيطر عليها شركه انفال وشركه للي ميعرفش
من حضراتكم مركز البيانات او الداتا سنتر
زي ما هو واضح قدامكم على الشاشه عباره عن
مبنى او مجموعه مباني بتضم كمبيوترات
عملاقه ومكوناتها مهمتها الاساسيه تخزين
التطبيقات والبيانات ومشاركتها بشكل سحابي
وبالتالي بتحتاج رقائق تقدر تعالج الكميات
المهوله دي من البيانات وده اللي وفرته
علشان كده ازدهرت اعمال مراكز البيانات في
الشركه في اقل من عشر سنين من 300 مليون
دولار كايرادات للشركه ل 15 مليار دولار
السنه اللي فاتت 2022 دخول انفيديا في
المنطقه دي والمنافسه فيها من عشر سنين
وقدرتها على جعل وحدات معالجه الرسومات
قابله للبرمجه كل ده فتحان رئيسها التنفيذ
جنسيا على حاجه محدش كان واخد باله منها
خالص بما فيهم الشركات المنافسه زي انتلو
ام دي وهي تطوير رقائق تقدر تتعامل مع
اعباء الذكاء الاصطناعي الراجل كان شايف
حاجه ما حدش كان شايفها ده اللي حرفيا كان
سابق عصر وبالتالي وجه الموارد
والاستثمارات في تطوير انواع جديده من
وحدات معالجه الرسومات الاكثر ملائمه
للذكاء الاصطناعي على مدار سنوات وشركات
رقائق الالكترونيه كانت نايمه في العسل
حققت انفيديا اختراقات مبكره في الذكاء
الاصطناعي بصورته الحديثه اللي احنا
شايفينها دلوقتي وهنا حد ممكن يسال امال
فين عملاق اشباه الموصلات شركه تي اس ام
سي تايوانيه من المعجنه دي مش المفروض
اكبر شركه في العالم لتصنيع اشباه
الموصلات اقول لك ده سؤال حلو قوي شركه تي
اس ام سي التايوانيه هي اصلا اللي واقفه
في ضهر بلدياتهم جونسون هونج وهي احد
الاسباب الرئيسيه في وصول شركه انفيديا
الامريكيه للمجد اللي هي وصلت له ده ازاي
بقى هقول لك من البدايه كان ملتزم انه
يخلي انفيديا شركه رقائق او بدون مصنع
يعني بتصمم الرقائق وتسوقها وتبيعها بس
بتستعين بشركه تانيه بتصنع مين الشركه
التانيه
بشكل اساسي وشركه سامسونج الكوريه
الجنوبيه بتصنع تحديدا الاجيال الحديثه
والمعقده من رقائق انفيديا وبالذات اللي
بيتم استخدامها في مراكز البيانات ومؤخرا
في تطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي خلونا نرجع
ثلاث سنين لورا وتحديدا لسنه 2020 السنه
اللي تجسدت فيها فلسفه وينج اجري ما تمشيش
السنه لتفوقت فيها انفيديا على اعلى
منافسيها اللي كانت لسنوات اكبر رقائق في
العالم وهي شركه انتل مثلا لو قارنا بين
القيمه السوقيه للشركتين من 2015 هنلاقي
القيمه السوقيه لشركه انتل اللي بيعبر
عنها المنحنى اللي لونه احمر كانت اكبر
بكتير من شركه انفيديا اللي بيعبر عنها
المنحنى الاسود زي ما واضح قدامنا وفي
تخطط القيمه السوقيه لانفيديا لاول مره
القيمه السوقيه لانتال وتجاوزت الميتين
248 مليار دولار علشان تبقى تالت اكبر
شركه لتصنيع الرقائق بعد الشركتين اللي
بيصنعوا لها وهم تياس ام سي وسامسونج
السبب الرئيسي للقفز الضخمه دي في اعمال
انفيديا في 2020 كان سياده الطلب على
شرائح الرسومات في مراكز البيانات ومجالات
تكنولوجيه تانيه سريعه النمو وباء كورونا
ادى الشركه دافعه قويه لانه صرع التحول
للخدمات الرقميه المعتمد على التخزين
السحابي اللي بيستخدم رقاقات انفيديا
بكميات ضخم وكمان الجماعه اللي بيعدلوا
العملات المشفره كانوا بيعتمدوا في
التعدين على رقاقات انفيديا ده غير ازدهار
السوق القديم بتاع انفيديا وهو الالعاب
ولانه كعادته لازم يكون سابق الجميع
بخطوتين اعلن في مايو 2020 في حدث انفيديا
جي تي سي عن الجيل الاحدث من القاقات
شركته المخصصه للذكاء الاصطناعي واحد من
اقوى اجيال الشرائح في العالم هو الوحش
اللي قدامكم على الشاشه ده انفيديا ايه
سعره 10,000 دولار الرقاقه دي بتحتوي على
54 مليار ترانزستور وادائها اسرع بحوالي
20 مره عن رقاقه الجيل اللي قبل كده اللي
هي فالطا وبتعتمد على معماريه سبعه
نانومتر من تصنيع شركه وطبعا ده كان تطور
رهيب في قوه رققاء اول طلبيه من الرقاقات
دي اتسلمت لمختبر اورجون الوطني التابع
لوزاره الطاقه الامريكيه اللي كان بيستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي وقوه الحوسبه وقتها لفهم
كوفي 19 ومكافحته بشكل افضل انفيديا قالت
ساعتها انه في عدد من اكبر الشركات ومقدمه
الخدمات والوكالات الحكوميه في العالم
اتقدموا بطلبات اوليه لشراء الالاف من
الرقاقه دي من وقت الاعلان عن الشريحه
الفديه ايه 100 مايو 2020 ولحد شهر مارس
هيمنه انفيديا بشكل شبه منفرد على سوق
الرقائق المخصصه لمراكز البيانات وتطوير
الذكاء الاصطناعي كانت سابقه الجميع ويمكن
بلا منافس في المنطقه دي فازت بطلبات
لتجهيز مصانع الحوسبه العملاقه في العالم
كله تقريبا طب ليه بقول لحد شهر مارس 2022
لانها جت في الشهر ده وقفلت اللعبه في
المؤتمر السنوي بتاعها
عن مجموعه كبيره من منتجات المؤسسات اللي
بتركز على الذكاء الاصطناعي من ضمن
المنتجات دي الوحش الكسل اللي قدامكم على
الشاشه ده الجيل الاحدث من رقائق انفيديا
فاكرين اللي قلناه من شويه عن رقاقه
دي احدث منها
شركه الذكاء الاصطناعي الناشئه
توليدي يعني انت بتمده بكميات رهيبه من
البيانات هو بعد كده بيولد بسرعه نصوص
وصور ومحتوى شبيه بالبشر زي ما حضراتكم
كنتم متابعين شاديه عمل ضجه في جميع انحاء
العالم وكان بمثابه ضربه البدايه لسباق
تسلح جديد في عالم الذكاء الاصطناعي
اتضربت طلقه البدايه من هنا وبدات شركات
التكنولوجيا الكبرى وشركات الذكاء
الاصطناعي النشائه ومزوده الحوسبه
السحابيه يتسابقوا لترقيه التكنولوجيا
مراكز البيانات الخاصه بهم طب ايه علاقه
تشاد جي بي تي بشركه انفيديا شركه اوبن اي
اي دربت شات جي بي تي باستخدام وحدات
معالجه الرسومات بتاعه وتحديدا احدث رقاقه
وهي الاتش ون هاند لانها اول رقاقه في
العالم مصممه للذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي
عملاقه الخدمات المصرفيه والاستثماريه يو
بي اس اندر ان تطوير شاتيه احتاج لحوالي
10.000 رقاقه انفيديا كان مجمعين مع بعض
في كمبيوتر عملاق تابع لشركه مايكروسوفت
قالوا ان هو شخصيا سلم بنفسه لشركه اوبن
اي اي او الكمبيوتر عملاق للذكاء
الاصطناعي في العالم وقال انهم بيتلقوا
طلبات مذهله لاعاده تجهيز مراكز البيانات
في العالم اللي بيحصل دلوقتي يا اخوانا ان
رقاقه
دي بتطور مراكز البيانات اللي كانت موجوده
قبل كده عشر سنين مثلا وبالتالي في تكالب
من جميع الشركات لاعاده تجهيز مراكز
البيانات بتاعتهم وتحويلها للحوسبه
المتسارعه واللي هتخليهم يقدروا يشغلوا
ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي التوليديه زي شتي
فكله بيعمل ترقيه طب الترقيه دي هتتكلف
كام يا ترى تريليون دولار من البنيه
التحتيه لمراكز البيانات وفقا لتقديرات
نفسه مين بقى اللي بيوفر رقاقات بتنافس
رقاقه اتش ون هاندرد بتاعه انفيديا حرفيا
مفيش حد تخيلوا ما فيش منافس قرب حتى من
تصنيع رقاقه شبهها او قريبه منها في
الامكانات وما فيش بدائل تانيه علشان كده
الشركات المزوده الخدمات والوكالات
الحكوميه في جميع انحاء العالم واقفه
بالطابور قدام شركه انفيديا منتظرين
حصولهم على رقاقه
لدرجه انهم بيتباهوا علنا بامتلاكهم كان
شريحه من رقاقات انفيديا وفقا لسي بي ان
سايتس فشركه بتمتلك حاليا 95% من سوق
وحدات معالجه الرسومات للتعلم الالي علشان
حضراتكم تتخيلوا المشهد الحالي بس الذكاء
الاصطناعي زي مانجا من الذهب بالظبط ناس
كتير بتتسابق علشان توصل الذهب اللي فيه
ولكنهم علشان يقدروا يعملوا كده محتاجين
معاول ومجارف واللي معه عدد اكبر هو اللي
هيوصل لمانجم اسرع ويعبي منه اكتر مين بقى
المحل اللي بيبيع المعاول والمجارف دي
انفيديا ومش بس بتبيعهم ده هو المحل
الوحيد اللي بيبيع يعني محتكر الادوات
اللي هتخلي الناس يوصلوا للذهب في المانجا
بين المحل او العملاء اللي واقفين في
طابور قدام انفيديا او الامثله بسيطه جدا
علشان الوقت خد عندك مايكروسوفت وامازون
وجوجل وماتا وشركات الذكاء الاصطناعي
التوليديه زي اوبن اي اي وانترو
باكشن اي اي وشركات عالميه ضخمه زي سايبر
اليابانيتين وشركه الاتصالات الاكوادريه
تلك ده غير مراكز الابحاث والوكالات
الحكوميه زي مختبر الفيزياء التطبيقيه في
جامعه جونز هوبكنز والمعهد الملكي
للتكنولوجيا في السويد هو احد اكبر
الجامعات التقنيه والهندسيه الاوروبيه
وغيرهم عشرات الشركات والمؤسسات حول
العالم والشركات دي مش بتشتري رقاقه
والاتنيه لا دول بيشتروا عشرات الالاف من
الرقاقات دي برانين ماكبي كبير مسؤول
الاستراتيجيات ومؤسسه شركه كورويف وهي
شركه ناشئه للبنيه التحتيه السحابيه بتركز
على الذكاء الاصطناعي وكانت من اوائل
الشركات سعيد الحظ
شحنات من رقاقه اتش وان هاندرد خلال السنه
دي بيقول ان رقاقات الاتش ون هاندريد
بتعتبر من بين اكتر الموارد الهندسيه ندره
على هذا الكوكب دلوقتي علشان كده بعض
العملاء انتظروا مده وصلت لست شهور علشان
يحصلوا على الالاف من رقاقات اتش وان اللي
محتاجينها في تدريب نماذج البيانات الضخمه
الخاصه بهم وبعض الشركات الناشئه في
المجال الذكاء الاصطناعي بدات تقلق وتعبر
عن مخاوفها من نقص المعروض من الاتش ون
هاندريد لان التاخير بالنسبه لهم معناه ان
في منافسين تانيين هيسبقوهم لو وصلوا
للرقاقات دي قبلهم في شهر ابريل اللي فات
الى الماسك قدر يشتري الالاف من رقاقات
اتش وان شركته الجديده للذكاء الاصطناعي
اللي انشاها مخصوص علشان تنافس شركه اوبن
اي اي من اقل من اسبوعين ماسك قال ان
الحصول على وحدات معالجه الرسومات في
الوقت الحالي بقى اصعب بكثير من الادويه
وقال ان تكلفه الحوسبه بقت غاليه جدا الحد
اللي بين انظمه ذكاء اصطناعي توليدي
والمنافسه مع الشركات التانيه بتبدا من
250 مليون دولار عباره عن خوادم حاسوبيه
بس ده بدون حساب اي تكاليف تانيه يعني
اغنى شخص على كوكب الارض بصافي ثروه وصلت
192 مليار دولار وقت تصوير الحلقه دي
بيشتكي هو كمان من ارتفاع تكاليف بناء
انظمه ذكاء اصطناعي توليدي مش فاهم يعني
المفروض نلم تبرعات للزميل ماسك ولا ايه
المهم ان زياده الطلب على رقاقات انفيديا
مع ضخ المستثمرين عشرات المليارات من
الدولارات في سوق الذكاء الاصطناعي اترجم
فورا لتضاعف قيمه الشركه اللي قدام
حضراتكم ده هو سعر سهم شركه انفيديا من
واحد يناير 2020 كان سعر السهم 59 دولار
فضل يزيد خلال 2020 وعمل طفره في اواخر
2021 قبل ما ينخفض شويه وبعدها بدا يرتفع
بقوه تاني بدايه من السنه دي 2023 لحد ما
وصل وقت تصوير الحلقه ل 393 دولار للسهم
الواحد يوم 24 مايو اللي فات اعلنت
انفيديا انها بتتوقع ان مبيعاتها هتوصل ل
11 مليار دولار في الثلاث شهور اللي
هينتهوا بنهايه شهر يوليو ودي مبيعات
باكتر من 50% عن اللي توقعها المحللين
فهول ستريت علشان كده تاني يوم على طول
وصلت القيمه السوقيه لشركه انفيديا لاول
مره لتريليون دولار وبالتالي بقت خامس
اكبر شركه امريكيه تتجاوز قيمتها السوقيه
التريليون دولار بعد ابل والفا بيت
ومايكروسوفت وامازون ومن خارج امريكا تيجي
بعد عملاق النفط السعودي شركه ارامكو ده
النادي السداسي الحصري للشركات الوحيده في
العالم اللي قيمتها السوقيه تخطط
التريليون دولار وطبعا الاكثر قيمه من بين
شركات تصنيع الرقائق في العالم وبفارق
كبير عن اقرب شركه ليها وهي عملاق اشباه
الموصلات التايواني تي اس ام سي اللي
قيمتها السوقيه وصلت النهارده
مليار دولار مش عايز اطول عليكم بس قبل ما
اختم كلامي عايزه اقول لكم ان القيمه
السوقيه لشركه انفيديا بالاسعار الحاليه
اكتر من خمس اضعاف شركه اي ام دي اللي كان
شغال فيها وانج قبل تاسيس انفيديا واكبر
بثمن اضعاف من شركه انتل وده على الرغم من
ان شركه سجلت ايرادات تجاوزت 63 مليار
دولار السنه اللي فاتت 2022
مقارنه ب 27 مليار دولار بس لشركه انفيديا
ده مؤشر بيوضح لنا المستقبل بتاع مين لما
هو انجل لنجح انه يخلي انفيديا قوه عظمى
للذكاء الاصطناعي اتسال من ايام عن
المنافسه مع انتل البطل السابق لصناعه
الرقائق قال نفس الشعار بتاعه عليك ان
ترقد لا تمشي لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي
وكالعاده عندي سؤال لحضراتكم تفتكروا ليه
ما فيش شركه تصنيع رقائق موجوده في الدول
العربيه وامتى هيكون عندنا شركات زي دي
هتابع كل اجراءاتكم في التعليقات اللي
عايز يشتري اسهم او ذهب ما تنسوش تشوفوا
شركه اكسنس هتلاقوا رابط تحت الفيديو ويا
ريت لو عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير
للفيديو واهم حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم
وحبايبكم عننا يمكن نستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]